it's michael j fox's back to the future
reunion you built a time machine kind of
a delorean i've always dreamed of seeing
the future looking beyond my ears
that's 82 year old christopher lloyd
sitting in a golf cart with michael who
gave fans a giant thumbs up marty
mcfly's reunion with doc at awesome con
comes 36 years after their iconic movie
premiered my god has it been that long i
love chris and chris is in his 80s now
he's a surprise
he's the same bouncy guy you know i
always was michael just turned 60
himself we spoke a few days after he and
christopher reunited last year lloyd is
a big supporter of the michael j fox
foundation for parkinson's research
after i saw
chris the other day on his birthday we
all feel the same way about each other
and protect the woman he loves that
includes michael's movie mom leah
thompson we got her to send him this
message i want to tell you how proud i
am of everything that you have done and
i love you and i'm very proud of you
she's she's amazing she was great to
work with like like she was a revelation
to work with you
you're my
my name is lorraine i saw what she was
doing and i went oh boy i gotta bring my
a-game to this
these people are good